la velocidad del sonido es de
aproximadamente 768 millas por hora
cuando un objeto se desplaza a una
velocidad mayor que la velocidad del
sonido provoca un boom sónico y bueno de
hecho esto de los bombs únicos es súper
interesante y por ahí en la página de
khan academy hay un muy buen vídeo al
respecto te lo recomiendo
pero bueno regresando a este ejercicio
nosotros queremos escribir una
desigualdad que represente a la
velocidad con la cual un objeto en
movimiento provoca un boom sónico y aquí
nos están diciendo que tenemos que
representar a la velocidad con una s
entonces pues hagamos lo que nos piden
vamos a escribir aquí la s que es la
velocidad con la cual un objeto puede
provocar un boom sónico pero luego por
aquí nos están diciendo que para que un
objeto provoque un boom sónico la
velocidad con la que se desplaza a ese
objeto tiene que ser mayor que la
velocidad del sonido y la
ciudad del sonido son 768 millas por
hora entonces ese tiene que ser mayor a
768 millas por hora ahora otra forma en
la que pudimos haber escrito esto
que pudimos haber dicho que la velocidad
del sonido o sea 768 millas por hora
tiene que ser menor que s la velocidad
con la que se desplaza el objeto que
provoca un boom sónico ok este es
simplemente otra forma de escribir la
misma cosa y de cualquier forma en la
que lo escribamos nuestra velocidad es
mayor que la velocidad del sonido ok
vamos a checar la respuesta
vamos con el siguiente ejercicio para
cocinar un filete de res a término medio
se necesita una temperatura interna de
135 grados fahrenheit una temperatura
interna más baja lo dejaría medio crudo
escribe una desigualdad que represente a
todas las posibles temperaturas a las
cuales el filete se quedaría medio crudo
ok entonces para que el filete se quede
medio crudo necesitamos que haya una
temperatura interna menor a 135 grados
fahrenheit entonces nos colocamos aquí y
sabemos que la temperatura tiene que ser
menor que 135 y aquí tenemos dos
opciones o utilizamos este teclado que
nos ponen aquí o también puedes usar el
signo de menor que que puedes encontrar
en el teclado de tu computadora entonces
te tiene que ser menor que 135 grados
fahrenheit
porque si la temperatura es menor que
135 grados fahrenheit el filete se va a
quedar medio crudo que es justo una de
las temperaturas que queremos describir
que hay entonces vamos a checar la
respuesta
mañana simón va a ir a patinar con su
snowboard si la temperatura es igual a 5
grados centígrados o hace más frío
escribe una desigualdad que representa
las temperaturas de las cuales simón si
va a salir a patinar con sus know word
entonces vamos por acá tenemos la
temperatura t
y pues sabemos que simón va a ir a
patinar si la temperatura es igual a 5
grados centígrados o más frío
y si está más frío la temperatura es
menor lo que hay entonces tal vez aquí
podríamos querer poner el signo menor y
luego el 5 de 5 grados celsius pero eso
no está completamente bien porque simón
también va a salir a patinar si la
temperatura es exactamente igual a 5
grados centígrados y por acá este signo
menor que ya no incluye a esta situación
cierto entonces más bien lo tenemos que
borrar y poner el signo de menor o igual
y ahora si ya estamos representando con
esta desigualdad todas las temperaturas
a las cuales está dispuesta a simón a
salir a patinar entonces vamos a checar
nuestra respuesta
ya terminamos